oh god oh i'm so sorry
if anyone is feeling good as hell at the
grammys this year
it's lizzo oh my god the singer took the
grammy stage to present the award for
best new artist
and let's just say she was really
excited
cause i love you
and my three shiny grammys that i got
last year
[ __ ] i'm back oh god oh i'm so sorry
the hilarity continued especially when
lizzo also fumbled while opening the
envelope
that revealed the winner of the category
shaking
fighting my war wait how do you open it
oh my god
okay i got it i got it i got it it's
time baby make a nostalgia
[Applause]
the moment quickly took an emotional
turn though as megan the stallion teared
up
while accepting the best new artist
honor i don't want to cry
i really want to say thank you to my
mama she's not here with me today but i
know she here with me at fear
and she always believed i could do it
the rapper caught up with e.t just
moments before her big win and talked
about how her mom who passed away in
2019
guided her to this moment my mom would
always say
we're going to be at the grammys and
blah blah like i will perform at clubs
bars anywhere i could perform i was
there and she'll be like one day we're
gonna be front row blah blah blah and
i'll be like
so far away but it came so quickly
and i'm just so happy what would she say
tonight because she's watching you you
know she's watching you i know she's
washing down over me
um she definitely we'll be in here
crying we will be crying together my
makeup will be terrible but i know she's
proud
uh her and my dad so yeah just shout out
to my parents for
making me they believed yeah believed
and this is her
this is her mom she really guided me
here yeah yeah so
this is all dedicated to my mom tonight